[Musique]
bein ma fille
il y a des choses que tu ne peux pas
comprendre et auquel tu est destiné tu
seras
c'est pas vrai quelle heure il est 3h du
mat il vous est déjà arrivé de faire un
rêve et à la dernière seconde tout à
coup vous vous réveillez et en fait tout
va bien et bat aujourd'hui c'est pas ça
le royaume entier a été changé en pierre
ma mère est démoniaque et elles font est
mort c'était le bon temps
elles font groupe tu puisses être je
suis désolé
bien sûr septième ciel pourquoi il gâché
un temps fou à rester en vie
un écran chat en attente pour monsieur
elf allô allô
l faut c'est bien toi un homme c'est
vous qui m'avez appelé je n'ai pas accès
au paradis baissier le faut nous
retrouvons en enfer je sais comment
sortir wind cabinet d'ado swim rabel
damon
[Musique]
qui est fou juanita il montrait qu'en
plus ça va les races et réaliste il y à
une prophétie qu'il faut accomplir
telle mère telle fille je suis pas comme
toi je vous à moi que vous vouliez voir
quelque chose de très cool
réal mais nous voyons cash on nous fout
cette pile de mouflets
il faut sauver l faut il rendre à
dreamland sa gloire quoi qu'il puisse
arriver
eh bien je me battrai
va falloir gérer ça d'une façon
dangereusement banque avait ce que
j'appelle la méthode dreamland
fitch suit son dragon que le meilleur
d'entre eux n'est le profond ou la
meilleure essayons de ne pas oublier les
femmes